Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. The day of faith has arrived. Against us, tyranny, the bloodthirsty and high standards, the bloodthirsty and high standards. Do you hear in the countryside the rumbling of these fierce soldiers The soldiers who come to your arms, Gorge your sons, your companions. To the citizens' arms,
感谢收听《历史的 rest》。如果您想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。信仰的日子已经来临。暴政正对着我们，嗜血之徒与崇高的标准，嗜血之徒与崇高的标准。你是否听到乡间这些凶猛士兵的隆隆脚步声？这些投入你们怀抱的士兵，大快朵颐着你们的儿子和同伴。公民们，拿起武器，
Form your battalions, March on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, march on, So A re venus So that was our producer, Theo Young-Smith. They were his dulcet tones. He was singing La Marseillaise, the song par excellence of the French Revolution, or at least the one French Revolutionary song that everybody now remembers. So Tom, that was adopted as the official anthem of the French Republic in 1795, but Napoleon didn't like it. He didn't.
组建你们的营，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，前进，S'est levée 所以那是我们的制作人，西奥·杨-史密斯（Theo Young-Smith）。刚才那是他甜美的歌声。他唱的是《马赛曲》，法国大革命中最典型的歌曲，或者至少是现在每个人都记得的一首法国革命歌曲。所以，汤姆，这首歌在1795年被采纳为法兰克福共和国的官方国歌，但拿破仑不喜欢它。他确实不喜欢。
He kind of pushed it back to the margins. And then after the revolution, after Napoleon, Louis the 16th's brothers, Louis the 18th and Charles the 10th, they come back. They obviously hate it, so they ban it completely. But the Marseilles is never forgotten. And it ends up as the national anthem of France. Theo sings it all the time as a proud Frenchman. Would you, I mean, you are John Bull incarnate, but would you agree that it's the greatest, the most thrilling national anthem ever written? I mean, the most stirring.
他有点把它边缘化了。然后在革命之后，在拿破仑之后，路易十六的兄弟们，路易十八和查理十世回来了。他们显然讨厌它，所以彻底禁了它。但《马赛曲》从未被遗忘。它最终成为了法国的国歌。西奥作为一名骄傲的法国人，总是随时随地在唱它。你会不会——我的意思是，你简直是“约翰牛”的化身，但你会不会同意这是有史以来最伟大、最激动人心的国歌？我是说，最振奋人心的。
Well, I saw you'd written this and this is the sort of slack and lazy thing that people who know only two national anthems say. So they know their own and they know one or two others. If they're American, they say that it's the American one. If they're British, a particular kind of Britain, they say it's the French national anthem. But actually people who know a lot about national anthems know that the best national anthem by far, so our assistant producer, Alia, will
嗯，我看到你写了这个，而这正是那些只知道两首国歌的人会说的那种肤色懒散的话。他们只知道自己的国歌，顶多再知道一两首别的。如果是美国人，他们就会说美国国歌最好。如果是英国人，某种特定类型的英国人，他们就会说这是法国国歌。但实际上，对国歌了解很多的人都知道，迄今为止最好的国歌——所以我们的助理制作人艾莉（Alia）会
back me up on this, is the anthem of the German Democratic Republic. Auf er standen aus Ruinan, the anthem of East Germany, which was an absolute banger and unquestionably the greatest national anthem ever written. Well Dominic, for those of us who aren't familiar with it, would you like to sing it for us? No. No? No, I wouldn't. You're clearly afraid to pitch it up against Theo's magnificent singing. No, I just don't want to look like an absolute fool.
支持我的观点——是德意志民主共和国的国歌，《从废墟中崛起》（Aufersstanden aus Ruinen），也就是东德的国歌，那绝对是一首神曲，毫无疑问是史上最伟大的国歌。好吧，多米尼克，对于我们这些不太熟悉它的人来说，你想不想给我们唱一段？不。不？不，我才不唱。你显然是不敢跟西奥那美妙的歌声一较高下。不，我只是不想让自己看起来像个彻头彻尾的傻瓜。
I don't think so. Because obviously as an Englishman, my soul doesn't stir with patriotic fervour when I hear the Marseillaise, except in Casablanca, that brilliant scene where the Germans are sat around the piano and then Humphrey Bogart agrees that they can strike up the Marseillaise and it's sung with such fervour and you are identifying with this and it's very, very stirring. However, I mean, it is worth mentioning for those who haven't looked closely at the lyrics, that they are incredibly martial. Yeah, the bloody standard.
我不这么认为。因为显然作为一个英国人，当我听到《马赛曲》时，我的灵魂并不会涌起爱国热情，除了在《卡萨布兰卡》里——那个精彩的场景，德国人围坐在钢琴旁，然后亨弗莱·鲍嘉同意他们奏起《马赛曲》，大家带着无比热烈的情感合唱，你会对这种情绪产生共鸣，这非常非常振奋人心。不过，我的意思是，值得一提的是，对于那些没有仔细研究过歌词的人来说，歌词其实极其好战。是的，血腥的旗帜。
Yes. I mean, it's kind of blood everywhere. Yeah. And it is summoning the Enfants de la Patrie, the children of the fatherland, to action. In that first verse that Theo sung so beautifully, France is menaced by ferocious soldiers who were marching beneath this banner of tyranny, which has been steeped in blood. And they're coming to rip out the throats of patriotic Frenchmen sons and wives. And so this great summons to arm citizens, form your battalions, let's march, let's march and irrigate the soil with a tainted blood. And the tainted blood is the blood of the tyrants and their armies. That tells you when it's written.
是的。我的意思是，到处都是血。是的。它在召唤祖国的儿女（Enfants de la Patrie）采取行动。正如西奥刚才美妙地唱出的第一首诗那样，法国正受到凶猛士兵的威逼，这些士兵踏着被鲜血浸透的暴政旗帜前进。他们来这里是要割断爱国法国同胞的儿子和妻子的喉咙。因此，这是一个伟大的召唤：公民们拿起武器，组建你们的营，让我们前进，让我们前进，用受污染的鲜血灌溉土地。而这受污染的血，就是暴君及其军队的血。这说明了它是何时被写出来的。
So war has been declared, but it also tells you about the mood at the time. So we've talked a fair bit about the paranoia, sense of conspiracy, sense of taint and impurity, invading the virtuous body of the French Republic. Tell us a little bit more, Tom. I know you've done some digging into this. How it comes to be written and who by? Well, it's written at a time when France is still a monarchy, just about. So it's written on the 25th of April, 1792, and that's five days after France has declared
所以战争已经宣战了，但它也反映了当时的氛围。我们已经相当多地讨论了那种多疑症、阴谋论感、以及侵入法兰克福共和国纯洁躯体的玷污和不纯洁感。汤姆，再给我们多讲一点。我知道你对此做过一些深入研究。它是怎么被创作出来的？是谁写的？嗯，它写于法国仍然是个君主国的时候，勉强算吧。所以它写于1792年4月25日，那是在法国宣布对
war on Austria. And officers in Strasbourg, who are kind of pretty much on the frontline, as a dinner, public dinner, and it's hosted by the mayor of Strasbourg, who's a man called Philippe Dietrich. And in one sense, he is the absolute embodiment of the intellectual revolution. The enlightenment infused revolution. So he's a Protestant. He is a distinguished scientist. He's a chemist. He's a geologist. He loves his enlightenment ideals. He sounds such a bore. And he's a Freemason. Total bore. Go on. But what makes it intriguing is that he is
奥地利宣战的五天之后。斯特拉斯堡的军官们，基本上就在前线，当时在吃一场晚宴，这是一场由斯特拉斯堡市长举办的公开晚宴，市长名叫菲利普·迪特里希（Philippe Dietrich）。从某种意义上说，他绝对是知识革命的化身。这是一场融入了启蒙运动的革命。所以他是个新教徒。他是一位杰出的科学家。他是个化学家。他是个地质学家。他热爱启蒙运动的理想。听起来真像个无聊的家伙。而且他是个共济会员。绝对的无聊鬼。继续。但有趣的是，他
simultaneously, he is the epitome of everything that the revolution is opposed to because he is an iron master and an industrialist. Now I do like an iron master. I know you do. And his forges are being powered by all the timber and the wood that he's been harvesting and which the poor can no longer use to keep their pots boiling. And so they're all starving. So he, he's a figure of sinister wealth. Um, and he's actually a former aristocrat. So he was the Baron de Dietrich. So he embraces all the contradictions and ambivalences of the revolution.
同时也是革命所反对的一切的缩影，因为他是一个铁厂老板和实业家。现在我确实挺喜欢铁厂老板的。我知道你喜欢。他的锻炉的动力来自于他一直在砍伐的木材，而穷人们为了烧锅取暖已经无权再使用这些木材了。因此他们都在挨饿。所以他是一个代表着阴暗财富的人物。嗯，他实际上还是个前贵族。所以他曾是迪特里希男爵（Baron de Dietrich）。因此他集革命的种种矛盾和矛盾心理于一身。
And it's not surprising that he should be keen on reinvention, the kind of reinvention that France itself in this period is having to undergo, the process of going from a monarchy to a republic. And it's of course, they are on the frontier of a country at war. And so at dinner, the toasts are offered exactly the kind that you can imagine. So to the atri, to liberty, to the ruin of tyrants, to the fertilizing of the soil with their blood and the blood of tyrants, all of that. And Dietrich, he finds all the words of these toasts stirring and he comments to the table,
所以他热衷于重塑自我也就不足为奇了，这种重塑正是法国在这个时期不得不经历的过程，即从君主制走向共和国的过程。当然，他们处于战争国家的边境线上。所以在晚宴上，大家互相祝酒，完全是你想象得出的那种内容：为了祖国（la patrie），为了自由，为了暴君的灭亡，为了用暴君的血来肥沃土地，诸如此类。迪特里希发现这些祝酒词的字句非常振奋人心，他对在场的
to the assembled officers, how tragic it is that all the marching songs that the French army have are rife with feudalism and superstition that they derive from the Ancien Régime. And he wishes that there was a marching song that would be appropriate to the new French army, an army of patriots and citizens. And it so happens that at that dinner, there is a captain called Roger de Lille. And he is almost a kind of mini Dietrich. He's a man of science. He's an engineer. He's a Freemason, but he's also a part-time composer. So he spent quite a lot of time in Paris rustling up various forgettable songs that he's trying to kind of flog to theaters and so on. But that night, the muse descends on him and he's inspired by
聚集的军官们评论说，法国军队所有的行军歌曲都充斥着封建主义和迷信色彩，全都是从旧制度（Ancien Régime）那里继承来的，这实在是一大悲剧。他希望有一首适合新法国军队的行军歌，一首属于爱国者和公民的军队的歌。碰巧在那场晚宴上，有一位名叫罗热·德·利尔（Rouget de Lisle）的上尉。他几乎就像个微缩版的迪特里希。他是个科学爱好者。他是个工程师。他是个共济会员，但同时他也是个业余作曲家。所以他花了相当多时间在巴黎四处搜罗各种过目即忘的歌曲，试图把它们推销给剧院之类的地方。但就在那天晚上，缪斯女神降临在他身上，他受到了
Dietrich's suggestion. He goes back to his quarters and he spends all night writing a song that he very catchily calls the song of the army of the Rhine. And I think that if that, you know, if it had stayed, that has stayed its title, maybe it wouldn't be as successful as it proves to be. And the next morning he goes to the Dietrich and he gives it to Dietrich himself who's very, very taken with it. And Dietrich's musical and his wife sits down at the piano, plays the chords and Dietrich bellows it out. And they all say, this is amazing. This is exactly what we need. And so Madame Dietrich scores it for a military band and the band strikes up and it's kind of literally a revelation because to quote David Andres in his wonderful book on the terror, he describes it as an almost millennial sense of drama.
迪特里希建议的启发。他回到住处，通宵写了一首歌，并给它起了个非常抓耳的名字——《莱茵军战歌》。我想如果这首歌、你知道的，如果它一直叫这个名字的话，也许它就不会像后来那样大获成功了。第二天早上，他去找迪特里希，把它交给了迪特里希本人，迪特里希非常非常喜欢它。迪特里希懂音乐，他的妻子坐在钢琴前，弹奏着和弦，迪特里希则放声高歌。他们都说：“太棒了！这正是我们需要的东西。”于是迪特里希夫人为军乐队谱了曲，乐队开始奏乐，这简直就像是一个启示，用大卫·安德烈斯（David Andres）在他那本关于恐怖统治的精彩著作中的话来形容，他将其描述为一种几乎具有千禧年感的戏剧性。
And there is that sense that I think in which it's a kind of secular dies irae. Dies irae, you know, the great medieval account of souls being brought before the throne of God to be judged amidst slaughter and chaos and bloodshed. And the lamb, the sheep and the goats are separated out. And this essentially is what is happening in the drama of what will come to be called the Marseilles. Well, it has that apocalyptic sense, right? Yes.
并且那种感觉是，我认为它类似于一种世俗的末日经（Dies irae）。《末日经》，你知道的，那是中世纪关于灵魂在屠杀、混乱和流血中被带到上帝宝座前接受审判的伟大描写。羔羊、绵羊和山羊被分离出来。这本质上就是后来被称为《马赛曲》的戏剧中所发生的事情。嗯，它确实具有那种末日般的感知，对吧？是的。
That is so common in the political culture at this point. So 1792, I read with great relish that the Marseilles, the music is probably not exactly plagiarised, but it's derivative. So there are various antecedents. There was an Italian composer called Viotti. There was an oratorio by somebody called Grison. And Mozart, Mozart piano concerto number 25, apparently, yes. Disturbingly similar, Tom.
这在当时的政治文化中非常普遍。所以在1792年，我津津有味地读到，《马赛曲》的音乐可能并不完全是抄袭，但它是衍生出来的。所以它有各种前身。有一个叫维奥蒂（Viotti）的意大利作曲家。有一个叫格里森（Grison）的人写过清唱剧。还有莫扎特，莫扎特第25号钢琴协奏曲，显然，是的。令人不安的相似，汤姆。
Well, remember that De Lille has come to Strasbourg from Paris where he's been stationed and he's been hawking his stuff around all the concert halls and theatres. So he's got a knockoff tune that he's trying to pass off to Dietrich. I guess in the way that minor composers, I gather, are often more prone to being influenced by things that they've heard, perhaps the very greatest composers, and he's clearly not a very great composer, but it wouldn't be surprising that he might kind of perhaps unconsciously plagiarize certain tunes that he's heard. Well, I mean, that's how musical composition works. But the bottom line is it starts to kind of go viral because soldiers from
嗯，记住德利尔是从他驻扎的巴黎来到斯特拉斯堡的，他一直在各个音乐厅和剧院兜售他的作品。所以他手里有一首拼凑的曲子，正试图塞给迪特里希。我想，就像我所了解的那样，低阶作曲家通常更容易受到他们听过的事情的影响，也许最伟大的作曲家则不然，而他显然不是一个非常伟大的作曲家，所以他可能会无意识地剽窃某些他听过的曲调，这也并不让人意外。嗯，我是说，音乐创作就是这么运作的。但底线是它开始像病毒一样传播开来，因为来自
Strasbourg, whenever, you know, they, for various reasons, they might be going back into the heartlands of France and they take it with them. They start kind of singing it. And one of the soldiers who does this is going to Montpellier in the south of France. There on the 17th of June, a doctor by the name of François Mireux hears it being sung by a soldier who's come from Strasbourg. He immediately recognizes it as something stirring, as something patriotic. He finds himself humming it and then singing it. He gets the lyrics. Five days later, he is going to a meeting at the Jacobin headquarters in Marseille. He himself is a Jacobin. He's a great enthusiast for the revolution. He goes to the Jacobin
斯特拉斯堡的士兵们，无论出于什么原因，每当他们返回法国腹地时，都会把这首歌带上。他们开始唱起这首歌。其中一个这样做士兵正要去法国南部的蒙彼利埃。在那里，6月17日，一位名叫弗朗索瓦·米雷（François Mireux）的医生听到了一名来自斯特拉斯堡的士兵在唱这首歌。他立刻认出这是一首激动人心、充满爱国主义色彩的歌曲。他发现自己情不自禁地哼唱起来，接着唱了歌词。五天后，他要去马赛的雅各宾派总部参加一个会议。他本人就是个雅各宾派。他是革命的狂热爱好者。他去了马赛的
club in Marseille and he gives a very fiery speech and brilliantly he ends it by bursting into song and singing this tremendous song that he's heard from the soldier from Strasbourg. And everyone at the club goes, yeah, this is fantastic and asks for the words to be written down and to be printed and to be distributed. Quick question. How does he know the song? Like there are multiple, multiple verses. How has he learned it? He must've got the lyrics from the soldier and the soldier must have got the lyrics because they've been printed off in Strasbourg. Oh, they've been printed.
雅各宾俱乐部，发表了一场非常激昂的演讲，最妙的是，他在结尾时突然放声歌唱，唱起了这首他从斯特拉斯堡士兵那里听来的、了不起的歌曲。俱乐部里的所有人都说：“太棒了！”并要求把歌词写下来、印刷并分发。简单问一下。他是怎么知道这首歌的？因为歌词有好几段。他是怎么学会的？他一定是从那个士兵手里拿到了歌词，而那个士兵手里的歌词肯定是在斯特拉斯堡印刷出来的。哦，它们是被印刷出来的。
Okay. So I assume that that's how it's been propagated. And Mireux is, he is a hot Jacobin. We talked about how this great summons went out from the capital to enthusiasts for the revolution out in the provinces to come and celebrate the Fête de la Fédération, which has begun to be celebrated annually on the anniversary of the storming of the Bastille on the 14th of July on the Champs-de-Mars in Paris. And so the people who come from the provinces to Paris to supplement the guards that are
好的。所以我猜这就是它传播的方式。米雷是个狂热的雅各宾派。我们讨论过首都如何向各省的革命狂热分子发出伟大的号召，让他们来参加联盟节（Fête de la Fédération）的庆祝活动——这个节日自巴士底狱陷落周年纪念日（7月14日）起开始每年在巴黎的战神广场（Champ-de-Mars）庆祝。因此，那些从各省来到巴黎、以增援巴黎革命当局手中可用卫队的那些人，被称为“联盟派”（Féderés）。米雷当时已经给自己登记成了一名联盟派。他是从南部招募的一支约500名志愿兵部队的一员，他们将从马赛出发前往巴黎，与来自全法国的其他联盟派会合。米雷被任命为这支向北行军的联盟派分队的总参谋部成员。他们于7月2日如期出发。
available to the revolutionary authorities in Paris come to be called Federe. Mirrored has already enrolled himself as a Federe by this point. He is part of a band of about 500 volunteers who've been recruited in the South and who are going to leave from Marseille and go to Paris to join the other Federe from across France. Mirrored is appointed to the general staff of this contingent of Federer who are going to march north. They duly leave on the 2nd of July.
他们武装到牙齿。他们拖着大炮，朝着巴黎进发。一路上，他们都在唱这首歌。德利尔给这首歌起的名字——《莱茵军战歌》，显然不适合这支来自法国南部的队伍。所以他们把它改了一个名字，听起来更抓耳，叫做《边防军战歌》。这歌太棒了。他们从马赛一路向北行军到巴黎，无论走到哪里，人们都绝对喜爱这首歌。
They are armed to the teeth. They are dragging artillery with them, heading off to Paris. As they march, they sing this song. The name that had been given to the song by De Lille, the song of the army of the Rhine, is obviously not suitable to a contingent of men coming from the south of France. So they change it even more catchily named the war song of the armies on the borders. And it's great. And they marched through from Marseille up towards Paris and everywhere they go, people absolutely love the song.
当他们来到巴黎时，我想这首歌的消息已经先于他们到达了。他们走进这座城市，他们歌唱的声音对于一个本已如履薄冰、兴奋、紧张、处于一种末日情绪中、做最坏打算、抱最好希望的城市来说，具有电击般的震撼力。它恰好触动了这根不可思议的心弦。这也提醒人们，此时的法国正处于君主制和共和国之间摇摆不定，因此需要国歌，需要新的国歌，能够以以往国歌所没有的方式来引导认同。
By the time they come to Paris, I think that news of the song has preceded them. They march into the city and the sound of their singing is electrifying for a city that is already on edge, excited, nervous, in a kind of apocalyptic mood, fearing the worst, hoping for the best. And it just strikes this incredible chord. And it's a reminder of the fact that at this point with France poised between monarchy and a republic, there is a need for anthems, for new anthems that can channel identity in a way that previous anthems hadn't.
所以如果你想想英国国歌，那是《天佑吾王》，它是围绕着君主制展开的，但如果你要废除君主制，你就需要新的歌曲，新的曲调。但你知道它有趣的地方在哪里吗？它并非完全没有争议，因为在接下来的几个月里，有很多人不喜欢《马赛曲》，甚至把它当成棍子去痛打别人。我在彼得·麦克菲（Peter McPhee）伟大的法国大革命史中读到，随着吉伦特派和雅各宾派之间的紧张局势和仇恨加剧，
So if you think of the British national anthem, it's God Save the King, it's focused on the monarchy, but if you're going to get rid of a monarchy, you need new songs, new tunes. But you know what's interesting about it though? It's not entirely uncontested because in the next few months, there are lots of people who don't like the Marseillaise and who you actually use it as a stick to beat other people with. So I read in Peter McPhee's Great History of the French Revolution that as the tension, the feud between the Girondins and the Jacobins became more intense,
吉伦特派实际上把《马赛曲》改编成了一个讽刺版本，他们在当年晚些时候将其作为一首圣诞颂歌分发出去，作者是一个叫安托万·约瑟夫·格罗萨斯（Antoine Joseph Grossas）的人。歌词开头是：前进，无政府状态的孩子们，耻辱的日子临近了，被愤怒蒙蔽双眼的人们举起了血刀。所以它实际上把所有关于血的元素都颠倒了过来，把它变成了一首歌颂无政府状态的歌曲，基本上把雅各宾派描绘成
the Girondins actually had a parody of the Marseilles that they used as a kind of, they distributed that later that year as a Christmas carol by a guy called Antoine Joseph Grossas. And it began, forward children of anarchy, the shameful day is upon us, the people blinded by their rage raise the bloody knife. So it actually turns all that stuff about blood on its head and makes it a song about anarchy and basically towering the Jacobin
这群嗜血的恶魔。我的意思是，我认为对歌词中好战血腥特质的焦虑从未完全消失。时至今日，法国偶尔仍有人提议或许应该重新改写歌词，让它不那么充满杀戮气息。但反过来看，正是因为它如此具有攻击性，才意味着那些沉浸在革命新阶段兴奋之中的人——
as these sort of blood crazed fiends. I mean, I think that an anxiety about the sanglary quality of the lyrics has never entirely gone away. There are still occasional proposals in France to this day that the lyrics perhaps should be rewritten to be slightly less carnivorous. But conversely, it's the fact that it is so aggressive that means that people who are caught up in the excitement of this new stage of the revolution,
也就是你在前面几集里称之为“第二次革命”的阶段——这正是他们想要的。他们想要那种毫无保留、直来直去的东西。这首因马赛人而被称为《马赛曲》（La Marseillaise）的歌曲，显然——这绝对是革命中更激进边缘的人们所想要的。而且我认为，不仅是歌词，不仅是曲调，还在于究竟是谁在唱它。他们不是职业军人。他们不是你在
the second revolution, as you called it in previous episodes, that's exactly what you want. You want something that is no holds barred. And this song that comes to be called The Marseillaise after these people from Marseille, the Marseillaise, clearly, I mean, it's absolutely what people on the more radical fringes of the revolution want. And I think that it's not just the lyrics, it's not just the tune, it's also the fact of who is singing it. So they're not professional soldiers. They're not people who you would expect
正常情况下会期望去唱行军歌的人。这些是在国家需要的时候响应祖国召唤的公民。当然，他们也是潜意识里的共和主义者。歌词中根本没有提到国王、王冠或君主制。在7月14日，即联盟节（Fete de la Federacion）的日子——这是对巴士底狱陷落和革命到来的伟大庆祝——他们在战神广场上占据了荣誉位置。这个巨大开阔地的名字充满了古风的韵味。拉丁语中的战神广场是 campus marshes。古罗马的战神广场正是公民们为了保卫国家、在国家需要的时候作为公民集结去参战的地方。
under normal circumstances to be singing a marching song. These are citizens who are answering the summons of their country in its hour of need. And of course, they are also implicitly Republican. There is no mention of kings, of crowns, of monarchy in the lyrics whatsoever. And on the 14th of July, the date of the Fede de la Federacion, this great celebration of the fall of the Bastille and the coming of the Fete de la Federación, this great celebration of the fall of the Bastille and the coming of the revolution, they have a position of honor on the Champ de Mars. The name that is given to this great open space is redolent with a sense of antiquity. The Champ de Mars in Latin is campus marshes. And the campus marshes in ancient Rome is where citizens would assemble to go to war
而马赛人高唱着这首对公民价值观充满暴力热情的歌曲的这一事实，给这种看似极其新颖的东西披上了一层古老的光辉，因为它赋予了它一种罗马式的特质。因此，西蒙·沙玛（Simon Sharma）在谈到《马赛曲》时写道，这是一首伟大的、激昂的爱国共融圣歌。没有什么能比《马赛曲》更接近于表达武装公民之间的同志情谊了，过去没有，将来也永远不会。但我想，对于受过古典教育的革命狂热分子来说，实际上他们有一种感觉，也许当他们在听这首歌时，他们听到的是那种
as citizens to defend their country in its hour of need. And the fact that the Marseilles are singing this song of kind of violent enthusiasm for civic values. It's giving to what might seem terrifyingly novel, a kind of antique sheen, because it's giving it a Roman quality. So, Simon Sharma writing about the Marseillaise, he says of it that it's a great swelling anthem of patriotic communion. Nothing like the Marseillaise had ever been written that comes so near to expressing the comradeship of citizens in arms and nothing ever will. But I think that for classically informed enthusiasts of the revolution, actually there is a sense that perhaps when they're listening to it, they're listening to the kind of song
可能曾激励罗马人或斯巴达人在共同的公民身份中投入战斗的歌曲。所以我一直在想罗马人会不会出场。他们果然出场了。我们休息一下再回来，去了解更多关于法国大革命中的罗马故事。《娱乐的 rest》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们还将拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目，以及提前购买现场门票的权限，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。这就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的 rest》。我们正在谈论《马赛曲》，汤姆显然认为这是一首绝对震撼的国歌。我对此有点怀疑，
that might have inspired the Romans or the Spartans to go to battle in shared citizenship. So I wondered if the Romans would make an appearance. They have. Let's come back after the break to find out more about Rome in the French Revolution. The Rest is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's the restisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest is History. We are talking about the Marseillaise, which Tom obviously thinks is an absolute banger of an anthem. I was a bit more sceptical, wasn't
对吧，汤姆？确实如此。但你现在已经转向这个故事中一个非常令人兴奋的维度，那就是罗马人。所以让我们深入探讨一下这个想法，因为我认为这贯穿了我们制作的第一季法国大革命以及我们目前正在制作的这一季，是一个非常有趣的内核：一方面，革命者认为他们正在重新开始世界。这就是它与美国独立战争或英国内战等事件的不同之处。这里有一种真实的感觉，即你可以重启历史，重启法国。
I, Tom? You were. But you've now turned to a very exciting dimension of this story, which is the Romans. So let's dig into this idea a little bit, because I think it's been such an interesting theme running through the first series we did on the French Revolution and this series that we're doing at the moment, which is about the interesting kind of paradox that on the one hand, the revolutionaries think that they're beginning the world again. And that's what makes it different from the American War of Independence or from the English Civil War or whatever. That there's a real sense that you can kind of reboot history and reboot France.
然而与此同时，他们也非常自觉地在角色扮演古代罗马人，扮演罗马共和国的仁人志士。你知道网球场宣誓是模仿贺拉斯兄弟（Horatii）的宣誓。我知道你要谈论大卫的画作了。所以这是一个贯穿18世纪文化的普遍思想，不是吗？启蒙运动文化，对罗马的痴迷——吉本的《罗马帝国衰亡史》就是一个极好的例子。但并不完全是罗马，对吧？所以他们痴迷的是罗马文化的特定方面和特定的历史时期。
And yet at the same time, they're also very consciously role playing as ancient Romans, as Roman Republicans. You know the tennis court oath modeled on the oath of the Horatii. I know you're going to talk about David's paintings. So this is an idea that has run through 18th century culture generally, hasn't it? Enlightenment culture, a fascination with Rome, I mean, Gibbon's decline and fall of the Roman Empire, a great example of this. But it's not all Rome, right? So there are particular aspects of Roman culture and particular time periods that fascinate them.
它不是基督教的罗马。我认为罗马之所以有如此巨大的吸引力，被革命者乃至启蒙运动中的人们所认同，是因为它提供了一种对前基督教秩序的惊鸿一瞥。嗯，因此有了吉本，对吧？吉本将基督教时期视为黑暗时代，现代性之所以成为现代，是通过回归古代、回归前基督教世界来实现的。所以这非常重要，特别是随着革命变得越来越反教权，甚至反基督教。
It's not Christian Rome. And I think a huge part of the appeal of Rome is that the revolutionaries and indeed people in the Enlightenment identify with is the sense that this offers a glimpse of a pre-Christian order. Well, hence Gibbon, right? So Gibbon is casting the Christian period as a dark age, that modernity becomes modern by going back to antiquity, to the pre-Christian world. So that's very important, and particularly for the revolution as it becomes more and more anti-clerical and indeed anti-Christian.
但它也不是凯撒的罗马。它是共和国的罗马，具体来说是在驱逐国王之后建立的早期共和国。法国革命者对那段罗马历史的钦佩，显然是在追随美国革命者的脚步，美国革命者曾将他们驱逐国王的行为视为充满布鲁图斯（Brutus）和贺拉斯（Horatius）精神的举动。我认为很有说明意义的是，甚至在革命的最早期，早在真正考虑废除君主制之前，就已经有了激进派。
But it's also not the Rome of the Caesars. It's the Rome of the Republic and specifically the early Republic that is founded in the wake of the expulsion of the kings. The French revolutionaries admiring that period of Roman history are obviously following in the footsteps of the American revolutionaries who had cast their expulsion of a king as something redolent of the spirit of Brutus and Horatius. It's telling I think that even in the very earliest days of the revolution, long before anyone is really considering getting rid of the monarchy, you do have radicals.
德穆兰（Desmoulins）就是一个典型的例子，他一直在这么做，他们把自己比作布鲁图斯。共和国历史上其实有两个布鲁图斯。一个是领导推翻君主制并建立共和国的布鲁图斯。但当然，还有另一个布鲁图斯，他是第一个布鲁图斯的后代，刺杀了尤利乌斯·凯撒。而尤利乌斯·凯撒是共和国的产物，却企图推翻共和国。拿破仑。所以拿破仑，是的，但也是所有那些让真正的革命者感到焦虑的阴暗人物，他们躲在爱国主义的面具后面。所以如果你扮演马拉（Marat）、罗伯斯庇尔（Robespierre）或任何声讨骗子、反革命分子的人，你就可以
Desmoulins would be a classic example, he's doing this all the time, who are comparing themselves to Brutus. And there are two Brutuses in the history of the Republic. There is the Brutus who leads the overthrow of the monarchy and the establishment of the Republic. But there is also, of course, the Brutus who is descended from the first Brutus who murders Julius Caesar. And Julius Caesar is a product of the Republic who aspires to overthrow the Republic. The Napoleon. So Napoleon, yes, but also all these shadowy figures that true revolutionaries are anxious about hiding behind the mask of patriotism. So if you're playing Marat or Robespierre or whoever denouncing frauds, counter revolutionaries, you can do
以布鲁图斯的身分，以一个致力于保卫国家免受暴君侵害的爱国者的身份来做到这一点。我们前几天谈论的那件事是什么？西塞罗。正是西塞罗揭露了卡蒂林阴谋（Catiline conspiracy）。是这样吗？这是件大事，西塞罗——他们对西塞罗着迷，不是吗？难道他们所有人都在学校里学习过西塞罗的演讲之类的东西吗？德穆兰，还有我刚才提到的罗伯斯庇尔。我找到了这段话，有一个叫罗莎莉·朱利安（Rosalie Julien）的女人，她是雅各宾派的同情者，她的日记和书信总是被所有革命史学家引用。她写到罗伯斯庇尔时——汤姆你会喜欢这个的——说他是个“把毕生奉献给公众、具有古代最伟大人物的慷慨的人。这个罗伯斯庇尔真是一个地道的罗马人。”
so as a Brutus, as a patriot committed to the defense of your country against a tyrant. What was the thing we talked about the other day? Cicero. It was Cicero who exposed the Catiline conspiracy. Is that right? That's the big thing that Cicero and they're obsessed with Cicero, aren't they? Haven't they all studied Cicero's speeches and things at school? Desmoulins and actually mentioned Robespierre. So I found this quote, there's a woman called Rosalie Julien, who's a Jacomet sympathizer and her diaries and letters are always cited by all historians of the revolution. She wrote of Robespierre, you'd enjoy this Tom, that he is quote, a man who was devoted to the public with the generosity of the greatest men of antiquity. This Robespierre is a real Roman.
我的意思是，再也没有比这更高的赞誉了。你提到了西塞罗，而蒂莫西·塔凯特（Timothy Tackett）在他关于恐怖统治来临的伟大著作中——我的意思是，他引用了一个惊人的统计数据：在革命期间的演讲和报纸中，西塞罗被引用的频率是当代哲学家让-雅克·卢梭（Jean-Jacques Rousseau）的十倍。所以你想想所有关于卢梭对革命影响的书籍、文章和论文，但西塞罗被引用的次数却是十倍。是的，我喜欢这个。它的影响在某种意义上显然是精英阶层的。嗯，是的，我正要问这个。大多数人并没有上很久的学校，
I mean, there could be no higher praise. You've talked to Cicero and Timothy Tackett in his great book on the coming of the terror. I mean, he quotes this amazing statistic that in speeches and newspapers during the revolution, Cicero would be cited 10 times more frequently than the contemporary philosopher Jean-Jacques Rousseau. So you think of all the books and articles and essays to be written about the influence of Rousseau on the revolution, but Cicero is being quoted 10 times more. Yeah, I love that. Its influence is obviously in one sense elite. Well, yeah, I was about to ask that. Most people don't go to school for a long period of time and
他们也没有学过古典学。对法国大多数人来说，这只是一片疯狂的胡言乱语。我认为这有点像人们今天可能会引用达尔文、弗罗伊德或马克思，而根本没有读过他们中的任何一个人一样。你有一种模糊的感觉。我们绝不会那样做，汤姆。众所周知，人们在没有阅读这些名字的情况下，也可能会抛出这些名字。就是那种情况。但我觉得它成了背景音乐，甚至成了色彩，字面意义上的色彩，因为这种“成为罗马人”的感觉，最主要是由你刚才已经提到过的一位伟大艺术家雅克-路易·大卫（Jacques-Louis David）培养起来的，他是一个痴迷于罗马的画家。
they don't study classics. To most people in France, this is just a mad babble. I think it's kind of in the way that people might quote Darwin or Freud or Marx today without having read any of them. You have a vague sense. We would never do that, Tom. It has been known that people might drop these names without having read them. It's that kind of thing. But I think it becomes the mood music, it becomes actually the colouring, literally the colouring, because this sense of what it is to be a Roman is fostered above all, I think, by someone that you've already mentioned, the great artist, Jacques-Louis David, who is a painter who's obsessed by Rome.
他的画作风格严谨，并且带着一种对罗马共和国早期高贵品质的自觉意识。他的画布一次又一次地描绘那些准备为国家奉献生命、甚至可能为了国家大义而牺牲自己孩子的男人，他们将爱国主义置于一切之上。大卫甚至在革命爆发之前就已经在画这些画了。当革命爆发，人们看到他的画时，就好像大卫在人们甚至还没开始行动之前，就已经为革命者描绘了他们正在做的事情。我们在这个系列里已经讨论过一点——对我们的美国听众来说还不够多——
His paintings are austere and self-consciously impregnated with a sense of the nobility of the early age of the Roman Republic. Again and again, his canvases are illustrating men who are prepared to devote their lives to their country, maybe even to sacrifice their own children in its cause, who put patriotism above all else. David is painting these even before the revolution breaks out. When the revolution happens and people look at his paintings, it's as though David has already been illustrating for the revolutionaries what they're doing before they had even begun to do it. We've talked a little bit in this series, not enough for our American listeners,
美国实验的影响有多大？因为在美国，人们已经在运用那个罗马模式了，因为如果你已经与英国分离，并且要在岸边建立一个新教共和国，去做一件前所未闻的事，你唯一能抓住的历史类比就是古典世界。所以他们在美洲这样做了。你认为法国人是在积极模仿吗？他们受到这方面的启发吗？法国显然有很多人深受美国正在发生的事情的影响。
we've talked about the influence of the American experiment. How much is this? Because in America, people are already using that Roman model, because really if you've separated from Britain and you're going to be a Protestant Republic on the shores of the Atlantic doing something that's never been done before, you've only got one historical analogy to grope for, which is the kind of classical world. So they're doing it in America. Are people in France, do you think, actively copying that? Are they informed by that? There clearly are people in France who are very, very influenced by what is happening in America.
你的朋友拉斐特（Lafayette）就是一个明显的例子。对拉斐特的巨大崇拜，是的。杰斐逊在那时是大使。富兰克林在革命前的几年里一直是巴黎的常客。确实有公开的革命者受到美国人榜样的影响。但同样，甚至连玛丽·安托瓦内特（Marie Antoinette）身边的人也是如此，比如朗巴尔亲王妃（Princess de l'Ombal），我们将在下一集中讲到她，她就是富兰克林的极大崇拜者。她认为服务于玛丽·安托瓦内特
Lafayette, your friend, would be an obvious example. Big admirer of Lafayette, yeah. Jefferson is ambassador in that period. Franklin had been a constant presence in Paris in the years before the revolution. And there are certainly overt revolutionaries who are influenced by the example of the Americans. But so too are even people, say, in the train of Marie Antoinette, so the Princess de l'Ombal, who we'll be coming to in our next episode, she was a great admirer of Franklin. And she saw no contradiction between serving Marie Antoinette
并与之关系密切，与钦佩美利坚开国元勋和美国共和国的榜样之间没有任何矛盾。我认为在大卫的案例中，他的早年经历了很多折腾，关于他是否能获得去罗马的奖学金，他觉得自己本该得到，但他的机会总是受到挫折。所以当他最终到达那里时，漫游这座永恒之城的机会对他来说就更加弥足珍贵了。我不认为美国介入了大卫与他对早期罗马的想象之间。并且我认为你在他的画作中看到的这种风格——带着一种严谨、缺乏
and being very close to her and admiring the founding fathers of America and the example of the American Republic. I think in David's case, there are huge shenanigans in his youth about whether he's going to get a scholarship to go to Rome and feeling that he should have had it, but he's always being kind of frustrated in the chance to go. And so when he finally arrives there, it's the chance to roam the eternal city is all the more precious to him. I don't think that America stands between David and his imaginings of early Rome. And I think that the look that you get in his paintings, which is kind of austere and lacking
任何浮华做作、并有着自觉的古风的风格——我认为这是他自己的风格。在革命期间，他将这种风格公之于众，因为人们认识到他在视觉上非常出色。正如其他许多事情一样，在革命局势中，人们需要一种新的面貌。他们需要对革命身份的表达，这些表达不能借鉴那些被唾弃和拒绝的东西。所以他就是那个例如在战神广场上协调巴士底节庆祝活动的人。当然，大卫完全认识到其中的罗马内涵，罗马式的回响。他正在组织——当伏尔泰的遗骸被运往先贤祠时，你知道的，先贤祠是罗马的一座大庙，由哈德良建造。嗯，它
in any sense of kind of flummery and self-consciously antiquarian. I think this is his own. And under the revolution, he brings this style to public display because people recognize that he's brilliant at the visuals. And as with so much else, in a revolutionary situation, people need a new look. They need expressions of the revolution's identity that aren't drawing on what is being repudiated and rejected. And so he's the person who, for instance, is coordinating these great festivals that are being held on the Champs de Mars on Bastille Day. And of course, David entirely recognizes the Roman connotations of this, the Roman echoes of it. He's organizing the, when Voltaire's remains are brought to the Pontian, you know, and the Pantheon is a great temple in Rome, built by Hadrian. Well, it's
最初是由阿格里帕（Gripper）建造的，然后由哈德良重建。但它是一座非常具有罗马风格的建筑。所以这同样是一种古典仪式，而且先贤祠最初原本打算是一座教堂。因此，这同样是用某种既是罗马的又是革命的事物来取代基督教的想法。林·亨特（Lynn Hunt）写了很多关于这方面的文章，她在这方面非常出色。我的意思是，她说没有仪式和符号就没有政府。你需要仪式，你需要符号，因此你需要能够创造和发明它们的人。抱歉，你刚才说取代基督教，但他们此刻并没有公开考虑取代
kind of originally built by Gripper and then rebuilt by Hadrian. But it's a very kind of Roman looking building. So again, it's a kind of classical ceremony and the pantheon had originally been intended to be a church. So it's this, again, this idea of replacing Christianity with something that is Roman and revolutionary simultaneously. And Lynn Hunt, who's written a lot about this is brilliant on all this. I mean, she says there is no government without rituals and without symbols. You need rituals, you need symbols, and therefore you need people who are able to create and invent it. Sorry, you said replacing Christianity, but they're not overtly thinking about replacing
基督教吧？这其中带有反教权主义的色彩，但他们并没有在想“我们要抹去……的每一个痕迹……”嗯，正如我们在下一集里将看到的，对那些拒绝宣誓效忠革命的教士的敌意，已经到了几乎充满杀戮意味的地步。是的。你昨天谈到，在杜伊勒里宫事件之后，当局出台了立法，甚至禁止那些已经宣誓的教士在公共场合穿神职服装。因此，我认为这是思想气候的一部分，对神职人员的敌意
Christianity at this point, surely? There is an anti-clerical tinge to it, but they're not thinking, you know, we are going to wipe away every last taint of... Well, I mean, as we'll see when we do the next episode, hostility towards those priests who have refused to swear the oath of allegiance to the revolution, well, it's on the verge of becoming literally murderous. Yes. And you talked yesterday about how legislation is brought in, in the wake of the Tuileries, forbidding even those priests who have sworn the oath to wear clerical garb in public. And so it's part of the climate of ideas, I think, that hostility to the priesthood
不可避免地蔓延成了对基督教本身的敌意。基督教与反动和迷信的联系——后来被称为“王座与祭坛”（Throne and Altar）——正在成为一个非常非常强大的推动因素。随着君主制开始摇摇欲坠，教会也随之动摇。最初正是教会批准了国王的涂油礼，将君主制尊为全能者赐予的礼物。因此，思考摧毁君主制，也就是在质疑教会几个世纪以来对法国历史所产生的影响。所以它成了必须被拒绝的一部分。我认为这就是在这个
inevitably spills into hostility towards Christianity itself. And the association of Christianity with reaction and superstition, thrown and alter it will come to be called, is becoming a very, very powerful motivating factor. And as the monarchy starts to totter, so also does the church. It was initially the church that had sanctioned the anointing of kings, that had enshrined the monarchy as a kind of God-given gift from the Almighty. And so to contemplate destroying the monarchy is also to question the influence that the church had and Christianity has had on centuries and centuries of French history. So it becomes part of what is to be rejected. And I think this is what is going on at this
时期正在发生的事情。因此，通过拒绝旧制度、拒绝基督教，古罗马就成了你自然而然转向的地方。是的。所以还有很多人依然不识字。因此，大卫的画作，或者它们的复制品——我想象中比如版画之类的——在传播这种古典美学方面一定非常重要。但我从你的笔记中读到，人们还可以购买各种纪念品之类的东西。比如胸针之类的。
period. And so by rejecting the Ossian regime, rejecting Christianity, ancient Rome is the obvious place that you turn to. Yeah. So there are lots of people who still can't read. So David's paintings, or reproductions of them, I guess, engravings and so on, must be very important in diffusing this kind of classical aesthetic. But I read in your notes that there are also kind of souvenirs and things that people can buy. So brooches and stuff.
句号。因此，通过拒绝奥西安政权、拒绝基督教，古罗马就成了你自然而然转向的地方。是的。所以还有很多人不识字。因此，大卫的画作，或者它们的复制品，我想，版画等等，对于传播这种古典美学一定非常重要。但在你的笔记中我读到，还有人们可以买的纪念品之类的东西。比如胸针之类的。
Yeah. Yeah. So you can buy brooches, which are stamped with the head of Brutus, and you can get pins in the form of the fasces, and the fasces are the rods that the lictors, who were the bodyguards of elected magistrates in the Roman Republic, would carry in front and before the magistrates as he walked through the forum or whatever. So people are literally dressing up as fascists. Right. So for us, fasces have this kind of sinister connotation because they give the name
是的。是的。所以你可以买到饰有布鲁图斯头像的胸针，还可以买到束棒形状的别针。束棒是罗马共和国时期民选长官的贴身保镖——吏长们，当长官走过广场或其它地方时，扛在长官身前和前方的棍棒。所以人们实际上是把自己打扮成法西斯分子的样子。没错。对我们来说，束棒带有一种险恶的内涵，因为它们赋予了
to fascism. But you can see in the seats of government in Washington, DC, the fascists are there. They're an inheritance from the American Revolution and the establishment of a Roman-type Republic there in exactly the way that the fast dates are being used in the streets of revolutionary Paris. Maybe that is an example of kind of an American influence, but again, I suspect not. I think it's part of the same impulse that both American and French revolutionaries are reaching for this classical heritage because it's just kind of part of the air of what educated revolutionaries breathing. Now let's talk now about how people look because obviously in some of these David paintings, he actually has people dressed in Roman style.
法西斯主义这个名称。但你可以在华盛顿特区的政府大楼里看到，法西斯标志就在那里。它们是美国革命以及在那里建立罗马式共和国的遗物，这与革命的巴黎街头上使用罗马速报的方式完全一样。也许这是一个美国式影响的例子，但同样，我对此表示怀疑。我认为这是同一种冲动的一部分，美国和法国的革命者都在汲取这种古典传统，因为这就像受过教育的革命者所呼吸的空气一样自然。现在我们来谈谈人们的外表，因为显然在雅克-路易·大卫的一些画作中，他确实让人们穿着罗马风格的服装。
So they looks like they might be wearing togas or whatever. And obviously people aren't walking the streets of Paris. I mean, they'd look ludicrous even by French revolutionary standards, but they are wearing Roman style hats, aren't they? They are, just before we come to the Roman style hats. I think Davi does actually struggle bringing the visuals of ancient Rome to the heroic moments of the revolution. So you mentioned this great painting that he's attempting to do of the oath and the tennis court, the moment when the third estate emancipates itself from feudalism and superstition, but
所以他们看起来可能穿着托加长袍之类的。显然人们并没有走在巴黎的街头上。我的意思是，即使按照法国革命的标准，他们看起来也很荒谬，但他们确实戴着罗马风格的帽子，不是吗？是的，在我们讲到罗马风格的帽子之前。我认为大卫在将古罗马的视觉效果带入革命的英雄主义时刻时确实感到了吃力。所以你提到了他试图创作的关于网球场宣誓的这幅伟大画作，那是第三等级将自己从封建主义和迷信中解放出来的时刻，但
he never finishes it. And actually he's kind of struggling to show the third estate as Roman. He can't quite decide how to do it. Is that not also the problem that while he's painting it, people who were previously good people have since been either canceled or executed? Yeah. So it's like photographs in the Russian revolution where people make the Stalin suddenly banish. So that is a problem. But one aspect of classical dress, which you alluded to,
他从未完成它。事实上，他在努力将第三等级表现为罗马人时遇到了困难。他无法完全决定该怎么做。难道这也是个问题吗？在他作画的同时，以前那些好人现在要么被取消资格，要么被处决了？是的。这就像俄罗斯革命中的照片一样，人们让斯大林突然被从照片中抹去。所以这是一个问题。但是古典服饰的一个方面，也就是你提到的那个，
which is a tremendous success, becomes kind of the emblematic symbol, the Republic, is the bonnet rouge, the red hat, the red bonnet, the red red cap. It derives from a soft cap called by the Romans the Pilius, which was given to slaves when they were set free. It was used by the Brutus who assassinated Caesar. He stamped it on his coins after Caesar's assassination to illustrate the fact that Rome, which had been enslaved by Caesar, had now been set free by the tyrannicides. It's conflated with a cap that had been worn by a people called the Phrygians who lived in what is now Turkey.
取得了巨大的成功，成为共和国的一种象征性符号，那就是“自由帽”（bonet rouge），红色的帽子。它源于罗马人称之为“皮利乌斯”（pilius）的一种软帽，这种帽子是给获得自由的奴隶戴的。刺杀恺萨的布鲁图斯曾使用过它。在恺萨被刺杀后，他把它印在硬币上，以说明被恺萨奴役的罗马现在已经由弑君者解放了。它与一种被称为弗里吉亚人的民族所戴的帽子融为一体，弗里吉亚人住在现在的土耳其。
It's also known as the Phrygian cap. It's adopted by the revolutionaries pretty much from the start. Certainly by 1790, they are saying this is, you know, this is the perfect symbol of Liberty. So as early as August 1790, proposals are being made in revolutionary and patriotic journals that say, you know, cocks on church steeples should be pulled down and replaced with the Bonnet Rouge. That would look absolutely ridiculous.
它也被称为弗里吉亚帽。革命者几乎从一开始就采用了它。当然，到1790年，他们就在说，你知道的，这是完美的自由象征。因此，早在1790年8月，革命和爱国报刊上就有人提出建议，你知道的，教堂尖顶上的风向标应该被拉下来，换成自由帽。那看起来绝对太荒谬了。
Ludicrous. And in the Cordelia Club, which is the most radical of all the Jacobin clubs, the rule is that no one can address the assembled delicates without putting on a Bonnet Rouge. And so in case you forget one, on the table, there are lots of Bonnet Rouge. So if you have to step up, you can pick one up and put it on your head. I think that's absolutely ridiculous. But anyway. Well, yes.
荒谬透顶。在科德利埃俱乐部，也就是所有雅各宾俱乐部中最激进的一个，规定任何人要在集结的代表面前发言，都必须戴上一顶自由帽。因此，为了防止你忘带，桌子上放了许多自由帽。所以如果你不得不走上台去，你可以拿起一顶戴在头上。我认为这绝对荒谬。但无论如何。好吧，是的。
And so there are people who think it's ridiculous. And one of them actually is Robespierre because in spring 1792, a motion is brought before the Jacobin club that all Jacobin should wear the Bonnet Rouge all the time. Right. And Robespierre who loves a wig, he loves a powdered wig. He doesn't want to go around with a Bonnet Rouge on his perfectly kerfured wig. And so he says it's ridiculous. A cocade is fine. We don't need to go the full revolutionary bonnet. Would they have to wear them in bed? I don't know. I mean, it's kind of a can of worms, isn't it? A can of worms. It retains its reputation as the emblem. But I suppose unlike the cocade, which is kind of like a
所以有些人认为这很荒谬。其中一人实际上是罗伯斯庇尔，因为在1792年春天，雅各宾俱乐部提出了一项动议，要求所有雅各宾派随时佩戴自由帽。对吧。而罗伯斯庇尔热爱假发，他热爱涂了粉的假发。他可不想戴着一顶自由帽走来走去，弄乱他那梳理得一丝不苟的假发。所以他说这太荒谬了。戴个帽徽就行了。我们不需要戴全套的革命红帽。难道他们连睡觉都得戴着吗？我不知道。我的意思是，这有点像打开了一个潘多拉魔盒，不是吗？一个潘多拉魔盒。它保留了作为标志的声誉。但我想，不像帽徽那样有点像
rosette, isn't it? Yeah. It's like a political rosette. A Cacade is kind of more obvious as a marker of political loyalty. But the Bonnet Rouge, if you were wearing the Bonnet Rouge, you were really kind of saying, this is what I am. This is what I'm about. And so in a way, the emblematic moment of the second revolution is when the people break into the Tuileries and they corner Louis and they make
玫瑰花饰，对吧？是的。它就像一个政治玫瑰花饰。帽徽作为政治忠诚的标志要明显得多。但自由帽，如果你戴着自由帽，你其实是在说，这就是我。这就是我的立场。因此，从某种意义上说，第二次革命的标志性时刻是人民闯入杜伊勒里宫，把路易逼到角落里，让他们逼着
him drink a toast to the Republic. But before he does that, they make him wear the Bonnet Rouge, the red hat. It's interesting, isn't it, how hats have this kind of political meaning. You would think that there aren't equivalents today, but of course there are. It was very controversial because people would often use pictures of when they wanted to be disobliging about Jeremy Corbyn, they would have pictures of him wearing a kind of, you know, I don't know, Maoist hat or whatever it is he used to wear or a kind of Russian style hat. And hats do, I mean, think about top hats or bowler hats, hats do actually have an oddly charged kind of political significance. And this is
他为共和国干杯。但在那之前，他们让他戴上了自由帽，那顶红色的帽子。这很有趣，不是吗？帽子竟然具有这种政治意义。你会认为今天没有对应的东西，但当然是有的。这曾引起很大争议，因为当人们想要对杰里米·科尔宾表达不满时，他们经常会使用他戴着某种，你知道的，我不知道，毛式帽子或者他以前戴的某种俄罗斯风格帽子的照片。帽子确实——我是说，想想大礼帽或圆顶硬礼帽，帽子实际上确实具有一种奇怪而强烈的政治意义。而这就是
the greatest example of that. Yeah. And it's recognized by contemporary. So a contemporary observer is quoted by Aileen Ribeiro in her book on fashion in the French Revolution. So this is a contemporary writing in 1792. The sight of a woollen bonnet rouge fills the sans-culotte with joy and let no one mock him for it. His enthusiasm is both praiseworthy and well-founded. He has been told that in Greece and Rome, this woolen cap was the symbol of freedom and the rallying sign for all those who hated despotism. With this in mind, his first desire is to become the owner of a Bonnet Rouge."
这方面的最大例证。是的。而且它得到了同时代人的认可。因此，艾琳·里贝罗（Aileen Ribeiro）在她关于法国大革命时尚的书里引用了一位同时代观察者的记录。所以这是一位同时代人在1792年写下的：一顶羊毛红帽子的出现让无套裤汉充满了喜悦，谁也不要因此嘲笑他。他的热情既值得称赞又并非空穴来风。有人告诉他，在希腊和罗马，这种羊毛帽是自由的象征，也是所有痛恨专制的人的集结信号。考虑到这一点，他的第一个愿望就是成为一顶自由帽的主人。"
What is fascinating, I think, about that passage is the reference to Saint-Colotte because it suggests how a symbol that is drawn from classical antiquity, which presupposes a certain degree of education, to be classically educated is essentially to be educated, is being paired with a style of dress that is emblematic of the slums of those who don't have the kind of classical education that the elites are expected to have. And of course we talked about the word son collot, about how to be son collot, the collot of the knee breaches that have become associated with the rich and particularly with the aristocrats. This is to look working class. So rather than
我认为这段话中最迷人的是对“无套裤汉”（Sans-Culotte）的提及，因为它表明了一个源自古典古代的符号——这假定了一定程度的教育，受过古典教育本质上就是受过教育——是如何与一种服装风格搭配在一起的，而这种服装风格正是那些没有精英阶层所期望的古典教育的贫民窟居民的象征。当然，我们讨论过“无套裤汉”这个词，关于什么是无套裤汉，“套裤”即那种与富人特别是贵族联系在一起的过膝马裤。这就是工人阶级的长相。所以，与其穿
collot, you wear loose baggy trousers, pantalon, you wear wooden clogs and you wear a short jacket, which in French is le camagnol. And this I learned from Eileen Ribeiro derived from Camagnola near Turin, which was home of Italians who had then settled in Marseille. So in other words, it's a particularly Marseille's look. Like the song. And again, it suggests the way in which the Marseilles are kind of perfect standard barons for this new revolutionary spirit. Yeah.
套裤，你穿宽松肥大的长裤（pantalon），你穿木屐，你穿短夹克，在法语中这叫le camagnol。这是我从艾琳·里贝罗那里学到的，它源于都灵附近的卡马尼奥拉（Camagnola），那里是后来定居在马赛的意大利人的家乡。换句话说，这是一种极具马赛特色的外表。就像那首歌一样。这也再次表明了马赛人如何成为这种新革命精神的完美标准旗手。是的。
A rough, tough port city where people, I guess, are seen as maybe as incarnating a different kind of France, but also more pure and more authentic France, perhaps. Yes. So the Sonkoulots, we talked about them a little bit last time. France, perhaps. Yes. So the sonculot, we talked about them a little bit last time. They are the kind of urban working class radicals, aren't they, of Paris. They're not the very poorest.
一个粗犷、顽强的港口城市，人们在那里，我猜，被视为化身了另一种法国，但也可能是更纯粹、更真实的法国。是的。所以无套裤汉，我们上一次稍微讨论过他们。也许是法国。是的。所以无套裤汉，我们上一次稍微讨论过他们。他们是巴黎的城市工人阶级激进分子，对吧？他们不是最穷的人。
Yeah. So they're not just the working class. They're artisans, but they're also revolutionary artisans. Yeah. So they have a class-based identity, but they also have an ideological identity. Yeah. And I think that what is fascinating about this period is that just as you were getting the working masses, the sonculote,
是的。所以他们不仅仅是工人阶级。他们是手工业者，但他们也是革命的手工业者。是的。所以他们既有基于阶级的身份，也有意识形态的身份。是的。而且我认为这个时期最迷人的地方在于，正如你所看到的劳动大众——无套裤汉，
affecting a classical look that derives from the education of the elites. So also are you starting to get elites who are dressing like the masses. And this is such a suggestive kind of cross fertilization. And the key aspect of this is effectively tr suggestive kind of cross fertilization. And the key aspect of this is effectively trousers. Yeah. If you're trying to pass yourself off as more proletarian than you are, you could change your name or something or drop the D or whatever. But the best thing to do is put on a pair of trousers. That's the street look. Yes. So the Giron d'Art ministry. So that that's Brisson and his allies who were appointed as Louis's ministers in March 1792.
模仿着源自精英教育的古典造型。同样，你开始看到精英们打扮得像底层大众一样。这是一种极具启示意义的文化杂交。而这其中的关键方面实际上是具有启示意义的文化杂交。而关键方面实际上是长裤。是的。如果你想把自己伪装得比实际更具有无产阶级气息，你可以改个名字什么的，或者去掉名字里的贵族前缀之类。但最好的做法是穿上一条长裤。那是街头风。是的。所以吉伦特派内阁。这就是布里索和他的盟友们，他们在1792年3月被任命为路易的内阁大臣。
They didn't last long. Louis Saxon in a disastrous move. But while they're in office, they are known as the St. Coulottes ministry. So these very, very educated men are being given the name of the St. Coulottes. And the most amazing example of this kind of class-based cross-dressing is the former Duke of Orléans, the cousin of Louis XVI himself, the man who had sponsored the kind of the early radicalism in the Palais Royal in the center of Paris, one of the richest, best-bred men in the whole kingdom, royal to his, you know, right the way in his blood.
他们没有坚持多久。路易在一次灾难性的举动中解雇了他们。但在他们任职期间，他们被称为无套裤汉内阁。所以这些非常、非常有学问的人被冠上了无套裤汉的名字。这种基于阶级的交叉着装最惊人的例子就是前奥尔良公爵，路易十六本人的表弟，那个曾在巴黎市中心的皇家宫殿赞助过早期激进主义的人，整个王国中最富有、教养最好的人之一，从头到脚血统纯正的皇室成员。
And he has taken on the name Philippe Egalité, you know, Philip Equality. I have to say, I'm just going to say it right now, he's one of the worst men in history. He's a terrible man. Well, he behaves very badly to his cousin. But in the summer of 1792, so while the massacre at the Tuileries kicking off, while the monarchy is in the process of collapse. Philippe Egalité, the former, the si devant du Cavalier is spotted by Madame Tussaud, the person who will set up the waxworks in London in due course. And she has a hilarious description of him. She says, he was wearing a short jacket, pantaloons and a round hat with a handkerchief worn sailor fashion loose around the neck with the ends long and hanging down the shirt collar
他取了一个新名字叫菲利普·平等（Philippe Egalité），你知道的，菲利普·平等。我不得不说，我此刻就要说出来，他是历史上最糟糕的人之一。他是个可怕的人。嗯，他对他的表弟表现得很糟糕。但在1792年夏天，当杜伊勒里宫的大屠杀开始爆发、君主制走向崩溃的过程中。前公爵阁下菲利普·平等被杜莎夫人发现了，也就是日后将在伦敦建立蜡像馆的那个人。她对他的描述非常滑稽。她说，他穿着一件短夹克、长裤和一顶圆帽子，脖子上松松垮垮地系着一条水手风格的手帕，两端很长，垂在衬衫领子下面，
seen above the hair cut short without powder. So no Rosbierre powder for Philippe Egalité and shoes tied with strings. So essentially it's kind of quite 60s. It's becoming cool for the upper classes and the elites to dress in a kind of a demotic manner. Yeah. He's the Theo of 1792, isn't he? Exactly. Except that of course, Theo doesn't dress like a Roman. This is the thing. It's simultaneously plebeian, working class, revolutionary and Roman because that detail, the hair cut short without powder. Madame Tussaud's description, she specifies that this is a particular style and it's called the Titus style. And the name derives
露在不涂粉的短发外面。所以菲利普·平等没有罗伯斯庇尔的香粉，鞋子是用鞋带系着的。所以基本上它有点像60年代的风格。上流社会和精英们以一种平民化的方式着装开始变得很酷。是的。他就是1792年的提奥（Theo），不是吗？完全正确。只不过，提奥当然不会像罗马人那样穿衣服。这就是关键所在。它既是平民的、工人阶级的、革命的，同时又是罗马的，因为那个细节——不涂粉的短发。杜莎夫人的描述中，她明确指出这是一种特殊的风格，被称为提图斯发型（Titus style）。这个名字源于
from the role of Titus in a play by Voltaire that he'd written several decades before. And this had been restaged in May 1791. It's a great celebration of kind of Republican Liberty and so on. And it had been played by France's greatest actor. And the name of this play is Brutus. So this style of hair is simultaneously, it's what you wear in the slums, in the working class areas of Paris, but it's also what you wear if you want to affect a Roman look. And so this, I think, is why the Marseilles has the impact that it does because it comes at exactly this moment when the Roman and the working class are fusing in the broad culture of revolutionary Paris. And they are arriving in their car manual, these jackets that are emblematic of the working classes. When they come to Paris, the first areas that they go through are those that are very self-consciously
伏尔泰几十年前写的一部戏剧中提图斯（Titus）的角色。这出戏在1791年5月重新上演了。这是对共和国自由等等的盛大庆祝。而且它是由法国最伟大的演员扮演的。这出戏的名字叫《布鲁图斯》。所以这种发型同时具备了多种属性：它是你在贫民窟、在巴黎工人阶级地区所戴的发型，但如果你想营造一种罗马风貌，这也是你的发型。所以，我认为这就是为什么马赛人会产生这样的影响，因为它恰好出现在罗马风貌和工人阶级在革命巴黎的宏大文化中融为一体的这一时刻。他们穿着象征着工人阶级的卡马约尔夹克到达。当他们来到巴黎时，他们穿过的第一个地区是非常具有自觉意识的
working class, particularly the area around where the Bastille had stood. But they're singing a song that proclaims civic and martial virtue in a way that Romans might have done. Of course, as we said, they're then assembling on the Champ de Mars, the campus marshes. And you said how the Girondins du Corse will be intimidated by it and put off by it and parody it. Even at the time, of course, there are plenty of people in Paris who were terrified by this display. So royalists in particular. So there's an officer in the Royal Guards who sees them, the Marseilles coming into Paris singing this song. And he writes that they are 500 fanatics, three quarters of them drunk, followed by the dregs of the people. But of course, Dominic, their rights are man who is on
工人阶级区，特别是巴士底狱曾经矗立的地方周围的地区。但他们唱着一首歌，以罗马人可能做过的方式宣扬公民和尚武的美德。当然，正如我们所说，他们随后聚集在战神广场（Campus Martius）。你说过吉伦特派当然会对此感到恐吓、反感并进行讽刺。当然，即使在当时，巴黎也有很多人被这种阵仗吓坏了。特别是保王党人。所以皇家卫队里有一个军官看到了他们，看到马赛人唱着这首歌进入巴黎。他写道，他们是500名狂热分子，其中四分之三的人喝醉了，后面跟着社会的渣滓。但当然，多米尼克，他们站在历史的
the wrong side of history. So the wrong side of history, Tom. So they have got an unnamed officer in the Royal Guards, a man of sense and discretion. He and I on the wrong side of history, Tom. So there you've got an unnamed officer in the Royal Guards, a man of sense and discretion, he and I on the wrong side of history, Tom, you're on the right side of history, aren't you? You do gooder with Theo, our producer. You're dressed in your street garb. Oh yeah. I love her Roman, Dominic.
错误一边。所以站在了历史错误的一边，汤姆。所以那里有一个皇家卫队里的无名军官，一个有见识、有判断力的人。他和我在历史的错误一边，汤姆，你站在历史的正确一边，不是吗？你这个老好人，和我们的制作人提奥一起。你穿着你的街头行头。哦，是的。我爱你的罗马风，多米尼克。
I look at you now in your street garb with your Roman haircut, shocking scenes. So everybody knows where we stand. So our plan was originally to get to the execution of the king and we've obviously completely failed to do that because there was just too much drama. So what we're going to do is we're going to bring down the curtain on season two of the French Revolution. But the good news is that we will be back in the spring
我现在看着你穿着街头行头，顶着罗马发型，真是令人震惊的场景。所以大家都知道我们的立场。所以我们的计划原本是讲到国王被处决，而我们显然彻底失败了，因为戏剧性情节实在太多了。所以我们要做的，就是为法国大革命第二季落下帷幕。但好消息是，我们将在春天回归
with season three and that will be more exciting than ever. We will get into the September massacres, to the fall of the monarchy, to the rapidly changing fortunes on the battlefield, and most excitingly to the trial and execution of Louis XVI. But next week we will be changing focus completely because we will be in America in 1968 for the fall of Lyndon Johnson, the assassinations of Martin Luther King and Robert Kennedy and in the long run the great comeback of Richard Nixon and the good news for members of the Rest is History Club you will get access to the entire America in 1968 series all six episodes on Monday and of course if you want to join the Rest is History club and sign up,
第三季，那将会比以往任何时候都更加精彩。我们将深入探讨九月大屠杀、君主制的倒台、战场上瞬息万变的命运，以及最令人兴奋的对路易十六的审判和处决。但下周我们将彻底改变焦点，因为我们将前往1968年的美国，去了解林登·约翰逊的下台、马丁·路德·金和罗伯特·肯尼迪的遇刺，以及从长远来看理查德·尼克松的伟大回归。对于“历史其余部分”俱乐部的会员来说，好消息是您将在周一获得观看整个“1968年的美国”系列全部六集内容的权限。当然，如果您想加入“历史其余部分”俱乐部并注册，
you just have to go to therestishistory.com. So on that bombshell, merci Tom, that was magnifique and a bientôt everybody. Au revoir. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
您只需访问therestishistory.com。带着这个重磅消息，谢谢你，汤姆，真是太棒了，大家再见。再见。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。